[Music]
no one welcome to this video this is
about drinfeld setups by black yeah what
does that mean the green felt is a
combination of the Moose d5 and a
king-size fianchetto which is kindly
same that we are doing Oh what we play
here is d4 Knight f3 g3 Bishop g2 as our
standard set up and in the green frog
black is doing the same we of course
have a chapter on the reverse green felt
so we are basically here when black
plays in a green felt set up acing a
symmetrical defense one way to reach the
main position of our chapter here would
be d5 93 9 f6p 3 3 6 3 2
evan castles castles and now we go see
for our standard move order basically
and yep black has a fundamental choice
of playing in a very solid fashion with
c6 after which I recommend to play the
move b3 and prepare the Queen side pink
arrow or they can play more dynamically
with taking on knight c6 or other
choices that are more non symmetrical
this is the main way to get to the green
felt starting position here the other
way is this one
where black is playing d5 now leading to
the same position one
they can play d5 any any move here if
for example or yeah which is maybe the
most frequently seen one and then again
we played C form this is the main chunk
of this chapter what happens after this
position after C form and there are
other ways to get there and we should
look at in particular one of them and
this is after d4 like not starting with
Knight f6 or d5 but starting with g6
this is a little twist we play Knight f3
Bishop g7 and now according to our
concept we play g3 I should mention that
black can also play d5 here which is a
bad move order due to c4
this is something that we will check in
in some in some minutes and now iam
Bishop g7 g3 and d5 here and this will
basically almost all of the time as
opposed to a regular mainline after
Bishop g2 most people play Knight f6 and
then we get this completely symmetrical
development that we have looked at and
that will be the main line there are
some and there are some off beat tries
that black may try and they should be
studied um at least briefly and an idea
for black is to play the movie 6 this is
rare but it leads to somewhat
unconventional positions we play castles
97 and replace' form the normal moves
basically and iam black most of the time
chooses the setup with Knight B to c6
that puts pressure on the porn they can
also a castle short after which I
recommend to play Queen c2 and after
Knight to c6 play with
give one set up this is the same thing
that I do recommend after night BC six
so it's basically a transposition so we
play something like this III cover the
d4 pawn I mean to see two rook to d1 so
this is the set up against this c6
Knight be in 697 build up something like
this looks very I think very harmonious
um you don't really need to know all
that much and it is a rather uncommon
variation um something like this could
happen between 2e to c5 this has been
played in a high level game Bishop b2
and we get to the hanging pawns here
that was played in a game URI cousin
John of 2014 and after Knight f5 white
had the typical central breakthrough
with d5 that happens so often in a
hanging pawn formation here white was
somewhat better because it was very
strong initiative for him um
again this six-night b c6 is a pretty
rare line but it doesn't hurt to have
seen it once another possibility for
black IAM is the move Knight to h6 this
looks a little bit odd but the night has
an idea going to f5 will put up lots of
pressure against deform and that is in
fact something that we should take note
off I recommend to Castle as always and
now Knight f5 and here we get to this
the position why it makes sense to look
at night h6 briefly because now the
solution to this is not so obvious um we
almost always play C form against this
kind of d5 setup um here this is not a
good idea
yeah because after the capture black has
immediately lots of pressure and we
don't get this back easily really not
and the compensation is actually
questionable really so we shouldn't do
that we have a different idea though and
it's I think something that is going to
lead to a small advantage for white for
sure there is a move c3
and it's a very uncommon in our
repertoire I rarely plays such a
smallish looking move but here it is
good the reason is that we are going to
play for the e4 break and this is
something that Black has neglected with
the knight being on f5 he doesn't
control he form um
now it could happen like this castle
it's 92 and now 96 yeah that's the way
for black to play this you just want to
prevent a fall for the moment and now
rook e1 simply preparing a form
yeah funny enough this position I had on
the board once but with black yeah that
was there was a funny funny thing who
rediscovered when I'm when I wrote this
course that I played this one with black
and that happened in them in the Belgium
league and I wanted to present my
opponent with some unconventional
problems the bad thing was he played it
perfectly
he played exactly like this and by the
time I already regretted my choice
because I really it's tough to see
anything better now for black then you
just play a normal developing when and
after E for D takes Knight takes to take
on e4 and then you wonder why on earth
did I play this this long night journey
when I ultimately take on any form so
this is I think just a bit better for
white let's look at two or three
continuation so back then I know I
considered Bishop f5 but after Knight
age form white gets a four in after all
and if you check this why this just
better you know this is a good maneuver
the knight can come to f4 and what is a
permanent problem if a black he cannot
really play c5 or a five that easily and
we have a couple of ideas sometimes you
can even consider to play h4 h5 and play
against and slightly um weaken King
Satya we're not on a forward to support
that
um I think white has a small advantage
here for sure
[Music]
going back to the position after rupee
one you could also stop f5 radically
yeah like in stone ball style um but
that is not an issue at all because if
you have looked at the Dutch chapter
already arm will do so in the future
mm-hmm in any stone wall we have a
standard set up we want a night on d3
and on f3 and this is something that you
can easily go for here yeah something
like this it's just going to be somewhat
better for white yam with the fianchetto
then we also have additional ideas that
are not so much happening in other stone
wall types for example h4 h5 can it be
an idea and also here sometimes we could
trade off this Bishop on h6 um we are
just going to be a little bit better
here note that still see for us on the
agenda in the future yeah so it's going
to be a rather um it's a bit odd but
it's a typical stone wall that can be
played similarly to the one starting
after one f5 and I ultimately played the
move b6 trying to develop and the thing
is white simply played you form and now
you don't really have much better than
taking there should be seven and then
ultimately I was in this position and
this is not very nice for black white
simply has pressure on the e-file and on
the pawn and it's really it's really
annoying
I went Knight f6 and my opponent here
played to move Knight e5 back in the
game and I was in in trouble yeah it was
just in trouble that is a good move you
can argue about this this is what I'm
recommending things is even better yeah
because you simply play this you play
rook t1 and you can't delay this idea
for the moment and when this is traded
those two bishops are traded then this
is six square becomes very weak
[Music]